Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today, we're going to discuss a great piece
of work that shows us how efficient and versatile
neural network-based techniques had become
recently.
Here, the input is a bunch or RGB-D images,
which are photographs endowed with depth information,
and the output can be a full 3D reconstruction
of a scene, and much, much more, which we'll
see in a moment.
This task is typically taken care of by handcrafting
descriptors.
A descriptor is a specialized representation
for doing useful tasks on images and other
data structures.
For instance, if we seek to build an algorithm
to recognize black and white images, a useful
descriptor would definitely contain the number
of colors that are visible in an image, and
a list of these colors.
Again, these descriptors have been typically
handcrafted by scientists for decades.
New problem, new descriptors, new papers.
But not this time, because here, super effective
descriptors are proposed automatically via
a learning algorithm, a convolutional neural
network and siamese networks.
This is incredible!
Creating such descriptors took extremely smart
researchers and years of work on a specific
problem, and were still often not as good
as these ones.
By the way, we have discussed siamese networks
in an earlier episode, as always, the link
is available in the video description.
And as you can imagine, several really cool
applications emerge from this.
One, when combined with RANSAC, a technique
used to find order in noisy measurement data,
it is able to perform 3D scene reconstruction
from just a few images.
And it completely smokes the competition.
Two, pose estimation with bounding boxes.
Given a sample of an object, the algorithm
is able to recognize not only the shape itself,
but also its orientation when given a scene
cluttered with other objects.
Three, correspondance search is possible.
This is really cool!
This means that a semantically similar piece
of geometry is recognized on different objects.
For instance, the algorithm can learn the
concept of a handle, and recognize the handles
on a variety of objects, such as on motorcycles,
carriages, chairs, and more!
The source code of this project is also available.
Yoohoo!
Neural networks are rapidly establishing supremacy
in a number of research fields, and I am so
happy to be alive in this age of incredible
research progress.
Make sure to subscribe to the series and click
the bell icon, some amazing works are coming
up in the next few episodes, and there will
be lots of fun to be had.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!